welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spiderman no way home rewrote
reality inside of the mcu in a way that
i'm not sure we're all fully
appreciating yet yes we are all crying
but later on in the bathroom we're like
oh wait uh how does that make sense and
also should i get that checked i'm
referring of course to doctor strange's
memory wipe spell that makes the whole
world forget that peter parker is
spider-man essentially unwinding
mysterio and j-jonah jameson's unmasking
him while also erasing peter himself
from the memories of mj and ned and
happy hogan and everybody so how was
reality changed exactly what exactly
does each character remember well after
giving myself enough time to process
this film and get parts of me checked i
got you covered here we go doctor
strange's memory wipe spell explain
so doctor strange calls this spell the
runes of cough call which strange had
previously used to make wong forget
about a full moon party in kamar taj
what happened at that party i wonder
what full moons was wong showing
everybody but while wong's memory of
that event had faded the event itself
still happened such is the case with
peter parker the world has forgotten
that peter parker is spider-man but
there is still a spider-man it's just to
everyone else he's now a masked mystery
figure once more but the problem is in
order for this memory wipe to be
plausible reality itself must also have
been warped physically for there to be
no record public or private of peter's
history as spider-man like you can't
have mj now thinking the that creeper
from the donut shop left a bunch of
shirtless selfies on my phone
the screenwriters acknowledged this
confusion in an interview with variety
to questions as to whether peter parker
has a social security number now the
writers grimaced and said they had
discussed it and that they considered
using the visual of characters fading
from photographs like in back to the
future to show reality warping co-writer
chris mckenna said obviously some sort
of magical redaction has occurred at the
end of all this we didn't want a lot of
people trying to do magical math in
their head sorry buddy you made a great
nerd movie with multiverse logic and
this is inevitable but according to
mckenna people had these experiences but
they start forgetting the person they
knew but they were still affected by the
events that happened so from this
helpful explanation and from evidence in
the film i think we can derive the four
rules for doctor strange's final memory
wipe spell in spider-man no way home
rule 1 everyone's still alive who knew
that peter parker was spider-man no
longer remembers rule 2 everyone still
alive who had any relationship
whatsoever with peter parker now views
him as a stranger rule 3 reality itself
has been rewritten to alter all physical
records of peter parker into a new
replacement history this includes photos
newspapers videos social media public
displays academic records and state
records the writers used the back to the
future photo fade example but harry
potter fans could also look at this as
hermione's sad obliviate spell and
deathly hallows which gaslit mr granger
and catelyn stark erasing hermione from
now very awkwardly framed photos and
rule 4 spider-man as a public figure
still exists in the historical record
but he was never unmasked specifically
people who knew peter's spider-man link
do not remember a blurry face or an
alternate face under that mask they only
have memories of spider-man as a masked
spider-man and any parts of those
memories that involve their relationship
with peter were replaced with different
memories so i know that's a lot but
let's go character by character to see
how this works for peter parker all of
his memories remain intact as they were
except now his external identity has
been reset like we see that he is now
studying for the ged which is a test
that you take as an alternative to a
high school diploma so that you can
apply for college or qualify for basic
jobs this means that peter's academic
record at midtown school of science and
technology has been erased and not just
from people's memories there is no
physical record of any peter parker at
midtown high however peter is renting an
apartment in manhattan for which you
need a state id at least so presumably
reality has been rewritten in a specific
way so that peter parker still has all
these basic things but his academic
history was so intertwined with his life
as spider-man that the spell just kind
of pulled a replace all there now when
we talk about peter parker's friends
it's important to note that peter
already had a habit of ghosting various
events so that ned mj and the rest all
have plenty of unaltered memories
without peter in them like in homecoming
peter bailed from liz's party he bailed
from the academic decathlon in dc from
the homecoming dance the field trip and
infinity war and several points in their
euro trip and far from home for most
midtown students it's sad to admit it
but these were mostly peter-free
memories already nedley certainly has
some peter-free memories from the many
times peter ghosted he just no longer
really knows why he was alone there and
if you were to listen carefully ned even
says he built that lego death star
mostly without peter's help you want to
build it tonight i can't tonight i got
to start
stark internship yeah exactly boys got
that internship
i'll knock out the basic bones of the
death star in my place and and then i'll
come by afterwards because for the most
part but still ned spent quite a bit of
time with his best bud like in class at
lunch on field trips all experiences
that ned must now remember as either
being alone or with someone else
hopefully with someone else unless he
wants to be alone there's nothing wrong
with being an introvert like in
particular for ned that crisis at the
washington monument now that he would
have no memory of peter parker giving
him that explosive chitauri tech this
was caused by some mysterious blast from
his backpack and thank god that spider
guy just happened to be there ned's
memory of their homecoming dance was
really just him with his academic
decathlon buds as we saw with that photo
of ned and mj just the two of them from
that homecoming dance without peter a
photo that appeared throughout
spider-man no way home twice in fact we
saw it once in peter's bedroom and then
again in the background of mj's bedroom
this prop might have been part of that
scrapped back to the future photo fade
plan that the writers discussed and then
at spiderman bar from home ned
originally was part of that seat
switcheroo that resulted in peter
sitting with mr harrington brad sitting
with mj ned sitting with betty brant
without peter requesting that ned might
not have ended up sitting with betty and
might never have had that summer fling
with her but otherwise his euro trip is
now marked by random attacks by
elemental monsters revealed as
weaponized drones interferences by
mysterio and from that night monkey guy
who knows if ned still would have
improvised that name and then of course
spider-man in london but also would have
had a random memory of him fainting in
his hotel room in venice now as we saw
in the no way home ending ned without
peter and his life got into mit and has
stayed friends with mj he probably still
has his hidden sorcerer talent since he
told doctor strange this is something
his nana mentioned was in his family
this was something independent of his
relationship with peter but now that ned
has no memory of discovering peter as
spider-man he never dropped that
finished death star lego set so he would
never miss the memory of him and peter
rebuilding it later in homecoming
however peter still possesses that lego
palpatine at the end of no way home he
also possesses a sewing machine to make
his new suit that looks a lot like the
one we saw in ned's nana's living room
so who knows peter might have found a
way to restore his buddy's memories we
won't know that until the next film now
when i'm not breaking stuff down i'm out
running errands i'm out walking the dog
and the last thing i want to worry about
is my earbuds falling out well with some
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit raycon's everyday earbuds
have optimized gel tips for the perfect
fit it makes them comfortable and they
don't budge thanks to raycon for
sponsoring this video listen to my music
while i feed this dog look i've been
over at everything and they didn't pop
out what a great fit
recon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever they offer eight
hours of playtime and a 32-hour battery
life that's long enough to listen to all
of hamilton in like two and a half times
if you're into that kind of thing
raycons are priced so that you can get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 48
000 five-star reviews and they come with
a 45-day happiness guarantee so click
the link in the description box or go to
byraycon.com
rockstars to get 15 off your raycon
purchase thanks again to raycon for
sponsoring this episode but on to
peter's girlfriend michelle jones watson
she was certainly one of those proud
loners that i talked about nothing wrong
with that she was often seen sitting by
herself reading and doodling she
actually admitted that she didn't really
have any friends because i don't have
any friends my friends call me mj i
thought you didn't have any friends i
didn't
mj would have stayed on that same path
she did by herself score the winning
point in the academic decathlon in dc
and then shortly after she directed the
mysterious spider-man to save her
friends in the washington monument all
that still would have played out the
same however there was no peter parker
in her class to fuel her suspicion that
this kid's recurring disappearances and
spider-man's coincidental appearances at
the same time were connected so mj never
would have found out who he was on her
own but in her academic career she still
would have become academic decathlon
team captain and she probably still
would have ended up at mit now mj like
ned was heavily involved with peter's
crisis in no way home but this spell
likely erased everything they did
alongside peter to capture the
multiverse men and to connect him with
his alternate peters now when that spell
subsided and these two just would have
found themselves on liberty island they
must have at least remembered being part
of all that since mj still had that bump
on her head at the end of the movie but
i assumed that they assumed that they
were visiting the statue of liberty they
got sucked into some crisis with at
least one mass spider-man but a mask
spider-man because mj may remember
falling from that scaffolding but i
imagine she now remembers the spider-man
who caught her was masked and that is a
very important point because ned mj the
rest cannot remember any blur or
alternate face under the spider-man mask
because then that would be associated
with the reality where spider-man was
unmasked and then scandalized that then
left them with a guilt by association
that doomed them with mit which is not
the case here since they got into mit in
a world where no one knows who peter
parker is however despite her brief
romance with peter parker getting erased
from her memory the spell did not erase
that broken black dahlia necklace that
peter bought her and venison gave to her
in london she continues to wear it the
necklace itself doesn't on its face
reference peter in any way so she may
just continue to wear it as a reflection
of her love for broken things i actually
like it better broken but come on the
true deeper significance of this
necklace is that this is a bit of
eternal sunshine-esque symbolism of
love's persistence beyond memory the way
that our hearts fill the vacant corners
of our lives with the person we know is
out there looking for us so once you're
done crying let's move on to flash
thompson flash's flashpoint tell-all
book certainly would have been erased
from existence now i'm not sure how
pivotal that book was to his getting
into mit considering that admission
officer totally rolled her eyes at it
and really people with actual
associations with peter parker got
rejected from mit so i think it was
really flash's rich parents who got him
in anyway his life pretty much unchanged
but happy hogan is an interesting case
because he remembers his relationship
with aunt may but not how may entered
his life now at her grave he told this
random kid that like him he knew mae
through spider-man so he probably still
knows that she was related to spider-man
in some way but not how exactly maybe to
her spider-man was just a masked
celebrity who supported her homeless
outrage and far from home but not her
nephew per se so his new memories likely
involve that assignment from tony stark
to transport this kid from queens to
berlin but that kid must have been
masked the whole time because happy
hogan cannot know who spider-man is now
in this reality but now we're getting to
peter's history with the avengers it
would be simple enough to say that peter
never joined the avengers for anything
but that can't be the case because
spider-man was still there with tony
stark in the avengers for all the events
he previously did civil war infinity war
end game the difference though is that
peter was now masked in all of their
memories because it's not possible for
spider-man to be completely extracted
from all that history because he played
too pivotal a role in civil war helping
team iron man and then infinity war
saving the lives of bruce banner and
doctor strange and saving the guardians
from floating off of titan and in an end
game it was the memory of peter parker
that inspired tony stark to give another
thought to time travel and it was peter
there in that final battle who passed
the gauntlet from person to person he
needed to be there and spider-man was
there for all of it the difference now
is peter throughout all of that never
took off his mask his identity remained
a secret throughout all of it and so
living avengers like bruce banner doctor
strange captain marvel nick fury
everyone who was at tony stark's funeral
they now remember meeting a spider-man
but not the kid under the mask this also
goes for the press and the public in no
way home after the spell j-jonah jameson
reports it's been a few weeks since the
fiasco with a statue of liberty and
spider-man's cultists continue to
contend that the vile vigilante is a
hero but if he were a hero he'd unmask
himself and tell us who he really is so
the public has no memory of peter parker
but the press continues to blast
spider-man as a vigilante involved with
the death of mysterio so the first part
of that broadcast in the far from the
post-credits scene still happened the
second part did not this would also be
the narrative of the surviving members
of team mysterio like william get to
riva guterman victoria who would also
maintain that spider-man whom they don't
remember unmasked was the one who
betrayed quentin beck now would this
also go for anyone off world at the time
of the spell like the guardians the
scrolls etc well yes many of these
characters did know that peter was
spider-man and if thanos's infinity
stone magic can affect people on more
than one planet at the same time
presumably so can the runes of cough
call peter quill drax mantis nebula thor
and the skrulls probably don't care that
much about the kid under the spiderman
mask anyway but for now he is a
forgotten memory to them now what about
other universes that is a trickier
question peter parker was not unmasked
and scandalized in other realities the
way he was in the mcu if we assumed that
unmasking was the main action that was
reversed i don't think the implication
was that this spell extends to all
realities especially when we know the
tobey maguire continuity had its own
doctor strange doctor strange that's
pretty good
but it's taken i would assume only the
doctor strange of that reality can cast
spells like the runes of kafka that
affect the characters in it but the
question we should still be left with is
whether tony stark still knew when he
was still alive in this revised history
arguably like with aunt may it doesn't
really matter now that they're dead but
stark might still have known since he
was the one who found peter parker and
designed each of his suits to be custom
to him but any records kept by tony or
by may like their photos of peter or any
conversations they had with others about
peter have now been erased from
existence however at the end of nowhere
home peter sews a new suit why not use
any of these stark design suits that he
had like the homecoming arrow suit apart
from home suit that he made in the
fabricator on the jet or the nanotech
iron spider armor or the hybrid suit
that we see at the end of the movie well
again this is not as simple as those
past suits fading from existence because
peter needed them to help the avengers
who all have histories inextricably
linked with spider-man in those suits
but perhaps the biometric scans that
allowed peter to operate those suits no
longer function because peter is not
registered in the software of the suits
as a person named peter parker does not
exist in reality anymore according to
the software so there you go that is my
best explanation of the runes of [ __ ]
memories of peter faded evidence that
supported those memories altered but the
little trinkets keeping the spark of the
memory alive remain you can support new
rock stars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you